hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Cypress
and we're gonna check out this trailer
cult for super smash brothers right now
I'm playing super smash brothers melee
allowing my sister mmm I [ __ ] love
that game an awful lot didn't play brawl
much promise good but I like I like
melee a lot and from what I've seen of
this I definitely want to play it - yeah
guess what I just got literally
yesterday pre-order a wii u wii u only
one now i was playing me reoccurred nice
it's gotta come over sometime we you
will I know I already made it a habit so
yeah he's over all the time and he
drinks all my beer that's sure I drink a
lot of his beer and use all of my hand
soap why do you use all of my hand soap
well I like to multitask when I go
number two oh god I shower in that room
I know I've seen you I've gone
I'm joking while you were showering so I
need a new place cuz then mine's going
to burn down watch the trailer brush
this trailer
Peggy twiddled Thank You Peggy ball
every time I see this it's just the best
[Music]
whoa it's like comic book lucky what is
this power
fire
yes
[Music]
whoa dear Oh cinematic clips look great
oh I don't like this game cinematic
closure
don't look that's great usually yeah I'm
like I'm wondering if this is what their
Cinemax will look like it's going to be
alright okay time to tip the stick Robin
bracelet nothing
smashing makeup all I get for it I am no
ordinary swordsman no you're not thunder
thunder
[Music]
Osprey three times I can only use them
so many times which is why I carry my
loving sword this is no time for me to
rest
who's he explaining all this that are
watts yes yeah I love the Japanese
[Music]
pretty cute the hero king himself
yeah Brady and hero of legend nice
indeed
I'm so excited for this game time to tip
the scales seasoned such an afterthought
they just wanted to clarify and see then
go oh yeah by the way it's like they
finished this whole thing that like
shout it to the director and the
directors like you do realize that key
and the female version of him are in the
game anyway I think it looks [ __ ]
just it's super smash and it's like you
don't want to change that much you just
want them to always amplify it a little
bit more and that's what they give you
and it's like yeah what's cool what's
reassuring is you know and I watch a lot
of these fighting game trailers I'm
always like us so complicated and the
Super Smash Brothers controllers are not
complicated
no it's pretty simple control like
they're fairly certain for anyone could
pick ups mash Bros and figure it out oh
yeah like that like it pretty much works
the same way for all the characters yeah
it's like B's special moves a normal tax
put the joystick this way and that does
the thing yes that's what's cool is like
your nature do-si-do characters yeah I
get to see what their powers are like
now you know so all of these these new
characters they just showed our Fire
Emblem characters now admittedly I don't
I haven't played too much of Fire Emblem
it's just kind of not a game that really
interests me it sister it's a strategy
RPG game okay so it's like playing a
very fancy game of chess gotcha with
magic and swords gotcha I was like like
when they for
introduced Marth and Roy in melee light
yeah I was kind of who the hell are
these guys that I played with them like
the first time again awesome awesome
they're awesome I love the firearm
characters I just don't I'm not too
familiar with their actual franchise
though well thank you guys for having
Dan on the channel so is the support
because he recommended the trailer so
thank you Dan
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe here to the real rejects and
dan has a gaming channel talks about
games like kinky games in the bedroom
you know what I mean yeah dance sex
expert sex therapist Dan Seibert Seibert
sex is a big part of it too
my second channel that launches next
year I have to give shoutouts dan okay I
want is that okay with you that's fine
with me cuz okay cuz I really want to do
this yeah you won't shut up about
Harrison Bittner and all he said and I
quote hello Ryan I'm new to your channel
and was wondering if I can get a
shout-out also the blonde girl is kind
of hot and the brunette sorry if I don't
know their names
I enjoy your videos and can't wait for
more I don't know why but I imagine
that's what Harrison sort of sounds like
like I thought he actually wrote this in
penmanship and then he was like oh wait
this is YouTube he dictated it you're
sick too alright take this down hello
right I'm new to your channel and I was
wondering if I could have a shout-out no
scratch that if I can't get to shadow
Thank You calories yes
start again sent from the blonde girls
named Adele brunette um is Alyssa or
Lauren which he probably would have said
the Asian yeah probably face it he would
have said the Asian I'm assuming that
hobby would a reference to Lauren's
[ __ ] Q man why did you indulge her
she's gorgeous
do you think to that face it's because
um his secretary was jealous of Lauren
and didn't want to write that down in
the comment ah fair enough
yeah professed his love to Lauren but
then the secretary is like I'm putting
this
Harrison I love you and you know what I
named after the greatest person ever
Harrison Ford how lucky are you pretty
damn lucky is the answer
DP builder we go hey hey Indiana are
people I really like I do Chewbacca good
do you run around and grab my labor
where's my family give me back my fam
Jimmy back my family just credible 9 hi
love your videos bro and can you give me
a shut up
respect from Australia hey he's from
Australia Australia easy he's a [ __ ]
OC hey yeah don't I don't even know what
to make of this voice here - right oh
yeah I do that in front of Adele all the
time hoping she'll get turned on it
hasn't worked yet ah that's what I was
looking for
yeah hasn't worked yet but one day now
I'm gonna [ __ ] you Oh Dell I barely know
you I don't know if I cross the line yet
um you did did I see I don't know I'm
just assuming half the things I say to
these women on the channel they could
get a restraining order
huh I'm getting a restraining order
oh you most definitely should yes even
in my position on this problem I have I
it that's right an order buddy
maybe you'll get out of my shower maybe
mmm look what kind of soap is that it's
really comfortable treat cheap Ralph
Kruger Wow who would've thought Ralph's
huh well they got like Whole Foods or
something getting it you think I'm a
cool foods money
what's wrong - anyway just credible 9
you're incredible Oh
rhyming right over here a mere zone 3
not a fan of the trailer but still
watched it for my boy Ryan hmm I'd
appreciate a shout-out homeboy you gonna
get a shout-out Amir zone 3 damn number
3 I would read some
I was there I give you a shout-out dude
oh the two of us to him you know double
a mere zone thumbless out out double the
shoutout double the shoutout
I hope he appreciates both of us
she doesn't know [ __ ] Cubs throat
alright